[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du 7 8 les invités une
émission vous le savez pour partir à la
rencontre de celles et ceux qui font
l'actualité locale et aujourd'hui parole
à hervé dussouy le président de la
délégation yvelinoise du secours
catholique l'association qui a dévoilé
récemment un rapport inquiétant sur la
pauvreté en france femme et étrangers
sont les principaux concernés vous
entendrez aussi dans cette émission
françois guillaume lorrain journaliste
au point et auteur de l'ouvragé de ces
lieux qui ont fait la france un ouvrage
qui nous en dit un peu plus sur les vies
les endroits emblématiques de l'histoire
de france on débute donc ce 7,8 invité
avec vous hervé dussouy bonsoir enfin
vous êtes donc le directeur de la
délégation yvelinoise du secours
catholique et vous êtes avec nous en
plateau ce soir pour parler d'un rapport
un rapport qui a été fait par votre
association c'est le 34e qui du genre
sur la pauvreté en france et qui
malheureusement dresse une nouvelle fois
un rapport on va dire un bilan
inquiétant de la pauvreté en france le
nombre de personnes qui viennent vous
voir au secours catholique et qui vous
demande de l'aide a encore augmenté en
2015 par rapport à 2014 +2 7% soit
précisément 608 1500 ménages que vous
avez rencontrés quand on parle de
rapports inquiétants comme je lé fais
est ce que c'est le mot juste oui c'est
à dire que on a eu à certains moments de
la velléité de dire on va éradiquer la
pauvreté et force est de constater que
on n'y est pas on n'y est pas non
seulement n'y est pas mais les chiffres
d'année en année continue d'augmenter
alors ils augmentent pour plusieurs
raisons il augmente d'une part parce que
les pauvreté sont très stabilisé avec
les taux de chômage qu'on connaît ainsi
de suite d'autre part parce que c'est
population augmente par un apport entre
guillemets de personnes extérieures qui
viennent se rajouter dans principalement
d'ailleurs dans les lieux de pauvreté
déjà le ménage qui viennent vous voir
vous par exemple secours catholique des
yvelines et ville pour quelle raison
quelles sont leurs difficultés au
quotidien
c'est se nourrir c'est s'est payé le
loyer alors oui c'est il ya un peu tout
ça mais mais la première raison n'est
pas celle là la première raison c'est un
peu étonnant mais la première raison
c'est avoir un lieu d'écouté d'accueil
où je suis entendu où je peux m'exprimer
où j'ai des conseils et un situe t c'est
leur première motivation la deuxième cas
c'est le côté alimentaire dans ce
rapport on comprend dans le rapport du
secours catholique il n'y a pas un
portrait-robot aujourd'hui de la
pauvreté en france tout le monde est
touché même s'il ya des personnes qui
sont peut-être plus soumis à 7 à cette
pauvreté les femmes et les étrangers
c'est les principaux concernés oui et
enfin le fragile ce sont eux les plus
fragiles du mois en ile de france si
vous prenez au niveau national on a dans
nous accueille à peu près 36 %
d'étrangers par contre si vous prenez en
ile de france on est à 65% d'étrangers
vous voyez que les proportions sont pas
les mêmes les étrangers arrivent
beaucoup de plus en région parisienne et
donc du coup l'île de france doit s'en
occuper c'est held qu'il incombe de
d'accueillir ces personnes là mais donc
on a une surreprésentation des étrangers
en ile de france les femmes isolées avec
enfants sont aussi en ce représentation
est là où là encore leur
leur situation s'aggrave donc
c'est un cercle st cercle vicieux
finalement c'est assez ambitieux oui
enfin c'est un cercle dont on voit pas
la fin dans tous les cas je sais pas si
c'est un cercle vicieux mais on voit pas
on voit pas le bout du tunnel sert que
de mois en mois sans arrêt la situation
continue de s'aggraver donc elle
s'aggrave aussi continue de s'aggraver
aussi dans les yvelines sur l'annoncé
que les yvelines initialement est un
département plutôt plutôt riche est ce
que c'est une idée reçue ça c'est pas
une idée reçue les yvelines c'est le
deuxième département le plus riche de
france donc ça c'est une réalité si on
prend le revenu un revenu par habitant
cela dit c'est un département dans
lequel la pauvreté existe aussi bel et
bien mais par contre elle est très
concentré dans un certain nombre de
lieux c'est du côté de trappes c'est du
côté de demandes du val fourré c'est les
mureaux enfin bong et un certain nombre
de lieux bien bien connu dans les
yvelines et toutes les pauvretés sont
concentrées là mais
pour répondre complètement à votre
question les yvelines c'est un
département qui a la chance d'être en
bonne santé économiquement relativement
bonne santé économiquement mais c'est un
département qui ne porte pas sa part du
fardeau par rapport aux de l'île de
france vous attendez quoi par là bas si
on dit qu'on doit traiter de façon un
peu équitable ont il faut qu'on accepte
de pas tout laisser en seine-saint-denis
quoi je grossis un peu le trait mais
c'est vrai que si vous prenez la seine
saint denis vous prenez le val d'oise ou
prenez paris institut tu nous en
yvelines on est vraiment dans une
position relativement confortable donc
je dis ça parce qu'on on crie très fort
dès qu'on parle de d'ouvertures de
centres d'accueil de migrants en
yvelines mais la solidarité voudrais que
mon père emporte nous aussi on va pas
laisser la part aux autres quoi c 'est
ya aucune raison qui justifierait sa
donc en terme de solidarité il est
logique normal qu'on cherche des lieux
d'accueil en yvelines pour que ça soit
pas dans les départements pauvres que se
concentrent toutes les pauvretés cc pas
c'est pas acceptable et tant qu'à faire
pas aussi les concentrés dans les
yvelines dans les lieux on va dire déjà
les plus pauvres il faut que ce soit
dans les territoires sahraouis et c'est
là c'est là que c'est un cercle vicieux
c'est d'une part ya pas beaucoup de
lieux d'accueil
ville résidentielle ça c'est un premier
point et d'autre part lorsqu'on veut
ancrer ou récupérer once upon a devant
soi une levée de boucliers des
populations et des élus qui disent pas
de ça chez moi donc ça veut dire que on
va retourner dans les communes pauvres
ou là on se plaint pas trop parce qu'on
a l'habitude de la pauvreté au delà de
ça on a l'habitude de la pauvreté la
pauvreté fait beaucoup moins peur parce
qu'on la côtoient on sait ce que c'est
alors que quand on est très loin de ça
on lui met une étiquette on lui met un
visage qui ne correspond pas à la
réalité c'est à dire que m'ont dit les
personnes pauvres ce sont des fainéants
ce sont des bons c'était ma question
suivante sur l'assistanat c'est ce qu'on
reproche souvent notamment dans les
débats publics politiques aux gens les
plus pauvres d'être assistés et
finalement on se rend compte dans votre
apport que c'est pas vrai il ya beaucoup
de gens qui sont éligibles par exemple
le rsa et qui n'en font pas la demande
mais vous avez vous avez un ce qu'on
appelle un non recours à un accès au
droit qui est considérable on dit on dit
les gens sont des profiteurs vous avez
un bon tiers des personnes qui seraient
éligibles au rsa qui ne le touche pas
soit parce qu'elles ont honte d'aller le
toucher soit parce qu'elle ignore la
procédure pour le faire soit parce que
c'est trop compliqué que ça leur échappe
mais elle a une nouvelle fois c'est le
fameux cercle vicieux oui enfin je sais
pas c'est encore une fois que si c'est
un service yooz met dans tous les cas ça
c'est un constat serre que les personnes
en situation de pauvreté sont absolument
pas le cliché qu'on veut donner d'elle
c'est il suffit de les approcher un peu
de les côtoyer pour réaliser que elle
souhaite travailler elles souhaitent
être autonomes elles souhaitent se
reconstruire dans dans la vie c'est pas
du tout c'est pas du tout l'image qu'on
veut représenter ça me choque
terriblement si vous voulez c'est comme
si on voulait faire porter aux pauvres
double peine c'est un non seulement ils
sont en situation de pauvreté mais en
plus il serait responsable de tous nos
maux ça c'est pas ça c'est pas
acceptable c'est pas acceptable ça n'est
pas vrai et pour justement que ça arrête
d'être acceptée aujourd'hui vous avez
lancé ce rapport au moment de la
campagne des primaires de la droite et
du centre est ce que c'est aussi le but
c'est aussi de faire entrer le sujet de
la pauvreté dans le débat politique
alors il se trouve que ça s'est passé
aux mêmes dates mais le secours
catholique chaque année fin novembre
publie son rapport sur l'état de la
pauvreté en france pour cette année il y
avait les primaires c'est pas nous qui
avons choisi la date des primaires à
d'ailleurs finalement mais ça tombait
bien et on l'a on a adressé le rapport à
tous les candidats de façon à ce qu'ils
puissent aussi s'exprimer là dessus vous
avez probablement remarqué que c'était
pas le sujet principal des débats et
vous le regrettez j'imagine est-ce qu'il
ya possibilité que ça change selon vous
est ce que vous êtes optimiste pour la
campagne qui arrivent pour les années à
venir j'en sais rien honnêtement je moi
je ne suis pas là pour militer pour tel
ou tel candidat ce que ce que l'on
souhaite nous c'est que ce sujet-là
s'inscrivent dans les débats de fond au
niveau des politiques publiques on a on
peut pas accepter que on est en ce
moment
des millions de personnes qui vivent
sous le seuil de pauvreté il faut que
quelque part le travail soit mieux
distribuer qu'on ait le souci de ces
personnes en précarité il n'est pas
logique que on est une société qui
tourne bien et puis pour un noyau on va
dire et puis toute une autre partie de
la population qui regarde cette société
tourner sans aide donc il ya quelque
chose qui qui qui tourne pas rond
l'annoncé c'est obligé merci à hervé du
sourire on continue ce set 8 invités
avec de la littérature et françois
guillaume lorrain romancier grand
reporter de l'hebdomadaire le point et
spécialiste en histoire qui était
l'invité de l'association plaisir oise
et lectures et dialogue il ya quelques
jours il avait présenté son ouvrage ces
lieux qui ont fait la france un ouvrage
qui nous en dit un peu plus sur les
endroits qui ont marqué l'histoire de
france on l'écouté au micro de mélanie
poker le livre ces lieux qui ont fait la
france c'est un périple que j'ai fait
dans tout l'hexagone et même en italie
pour partir à la recherche de 26 lieux
très différents qui ont marqués chacun à
leur manière notre histoire des lieux de
bataille des lieux de l'invention des
lieux industriels agricoles et les
artistique et je travaille en fait sur
la sur la mémoire des lieux au seigneur
en fait sur les traces que laissent
l'événement l'histoire quand elles
arrivent dans ces lieux
depuis donc le moment où l événement
jusqu'à aujourd'hui pourquoi par exemple
quand on va dont rémy on trouve la
maison natale dans cet état là quelle
est l'histoire de cette maison pourquoi
il ya aussi une basique ou est-ce
qu'elle sort qui ont été construites et
pourquoi il ya un énorme musée qui
écrase et 10 figurent le village je suis
parti dans 26 endroit avec toujours
comme relais des gens qui sur place des
gens du cru qui m'ont aidé et on trouve
m'ont transmis un peu tout un savoir
qu'il n'est pas dans forcément dans les
livres sur ceux sur ces lieux là et
pourquoi ces 26 lieux là en particulier
ils avaient des incontournables c'est à
dire des mythes pour nous dans notre
imaginaire comme marignan comme comme
bouvines sont des batailles comme valmy
com après il y avait des petits plaisirs
que je voulais m'offrir je voulais
refaire la fuite du roi louis saez
havane je vais savoir exactement comment
ça s'était passé ce drame pourquoi il
est s était arrêtée qu'est ce qui
s'était passé dans cette rue
ensuite il y avait d d d histoire peu
connue que j'avais rencontrés dans mon
travail au point
j'avais entendu parler là je voulais
profiter l'occasion d'un livre chaque
chapitre fait à peu près une vingtaine
25 pages donc d'avoir la place ça
pouvait être par exemple une histoire
aussi insolite que la reconstruction des
tueries en corse ou bien transfert dans
une abbaye dans en aveyron tous les
tableaux du louvre pendant la guerre 1
je vais d'abord fait mes devoirs avant
de partir c'est je regardais je lisais
un peu ce qu'ils avaient sur le sujet
avant de partir aussi je contactais
j'essaie de trouver les bonnes personnes
mais bon relais est bon pour son pilote
qui était alors c'était toutes sortes de
personnes ça pouvait être un curé ça
vous fait un prof ça pouvait être un élu
quelqu'un exclu une association
passionnés ou plus dans la fois plus
parfois je faisais des sondages sur
place parce que je voulais avoir aussi
manière dont les événements et s'était
inscrit dans la mémoire collective comme
à montoir par exemple poignet mais un
truc un pépin comment est ce qu'on vit
avec la honte la collaboration donc je
vais bien je fais sont à chaud toute la
place du village
mais ensuite j'ai fait relire chaque
chapitre
par un historien spécialiste de la
période c'est la fin de ce set 8 les
invités une émission à revoir en replay
sur notre site internet tv fil 78 points
comme sinon rendez vous demain même
heure bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]